i love your outfit you know no big deal
just on the root grandma show
tried to show off a little bit i love
your book
how did you first get into the meat
industry l'oreal
oh drew i've been cooking my whole life
i'm 33 now
started when i was 15. my grandma had a
huge
impact on me growing up so i've been
cooking a long time
and part of being a chef was they never
really touched on
the meat industry fabrication artisan
cuts so i had an
opportunity to take a job years ago and
i can't believe all the doors that
opened for me
now like talk about your experience
like you're a woman it's a male
dominated field
you wanted to get into artisan cuts how
did that all come about
well i never noticed in the midst of
doing
things that are mostly known as male
traits
that i was a woman doing them like as a
chef i'm constantly surrounded by
dudes i love to ride motorcycles i play
music
so i guess i just like dude stuff and i
like to wear lipstick so
i never really noticed i wasn't like
where i was supposed to be you know
i really relate to that because i feel
like i have a tomboy
alive inside of me but i guess i'm
inherently a girl and i love women
so i really appreciate everything you
just said i feel the same way
well being being in television too i
realized the importance of
having a thick skin and a pretty face
you know what i'm saying
you got to kind of have it all you know
okay l'oreal
why is that not on every t-shirt and
billboard
and you do have to have a tough skin you
know
you really do i had to hear things all
the time that are
hard to hear and i'm glad that we can
handle it
and what is your message for young girls
who
may want to become butchers themselves
one day and be
artisanal about the approach
well my biggest thing is stay hungry and
don't
not reach out to your homies there are
tons of amazing beautiful women
out there who want to like give you a
leg up you know what i mean
and i think a lot of times as women
years and years ago
women didn't want to help other women
out they didn't necessarily want to give
them
pointers or let them know how they got
to be where they are being successful
and like those things are done like i
love just celebrating women in general
like if you look good and i see you on
the street i'ma tell you look beautiful
and like we need more energy out there
so these women just need to get on the
internet type in there's tons of uh
there's tons of groups you can join like
there's no excuse with the internet
you know what again i'm gonna agree with
you l'oreal because when we did
charlie's angels people were like
are the girls gonna be cat fighting and
i was like no they're gonna be best
friends lift each other up
like talk about dating while they're
kicking butt and
you know cat fights used to be the
standard and now
i think women supporting women is the
standard and i'm so glad to see that
i really want to ask you a question that
i found really important
what are your three money-saving tips
when it comes to buying meat
well first off buy in bulk you can save
a lot of money
when you buy bigger pieces of meat and
when you shop at an amazing butcher shop
they're going to cut it up for you any
way that you want secondly
don't be afraid to shop for those
tougher cuts of me
a lot of times they're going to be less
expensive and there are some of the most
beautiful cuts of meat at the end of the
day by the time they get to the table
for example beef bargain yawn it's a
chaperone it's a tough and expensive cup
and last but not least be nice talk to
your butchers get a relationship with
them
ask them how they are bring them a cup
of coffee because we'll hook you up
a little bit of kindness seriously goes
a super long way
oh lori al i just
love everything you are saying
[Music]
you